homeland in space a brutal butcher
murder and an extended love sausage
scene
are just a few of the boys season two's
most twisted deleted scenes
yipikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'm revealing the original ending
to the second season
plus seven more deleted scenes you never
got to see obviously spoilers ahead so
take care
by the end of season 2 homelander finds
himself defeated on numerous fronts
he's lost his son ryan to butcher
stormfront has been maimed and exposed
as a nazi
and he's been blackmailed by maeve into
welcoming starlight back into the seven
so by his final scene he attempts to
heal his bruised ego on the new york
rooftops repeating to himself i can do
whatever i want
however the boys showrunner eric kripke
has now revealed an alternate ending
with homelander in space
instead speaking to the rap kripke said
that originally homelander was hovering
over the earth like superman does but he
had a scary sociopathic look
according to kripke the scene was
actually filmed and was
awesome but amazon asked if they could
stick the landing on homeland a little
harder and have something that maybe
wasn't quite as ambiguous
so kripke decided to go back to a season
one deleted scene of homelander on the
chrysler building
which interestingly amazon had refused
to allow at the time
and he submitted that as the new season
2 ending
amazon preferred this recycled finale
because as kripky says it's telling us
something about how powerless and
pathetic homelander feels in that moment
and how dangerous he'll be moving into
season three
i can see why they opted to change the
ending but personally i think
a really menacing scene of homelander in
space looking down on earth would have
been even more interesting
as it would look like he's threatening
the whole world
and it would have tied in stronger with
the idea that's been building in season
two that homelander could go
completely off the rails at any point
for example there was the moment where
he imagined himself massacring the crowd
who were booing him
and there was the threat he made to
maeve in the final episode if she
released the video of the airplane
incident
if you do that i'll destroy everything
and after a train is ejected from the
seven he becomes desperate to get back
in the team and there's a great deleted
scene which sheds a lot more light on
his motivations to return to the
spotlight
in the cut scene a train visits his
financial advisor to discover that
despite the fact that he earns over 40
million a year he has less than a
quarter of a million left
240 thousand dollars nah this can't be
right
run those numbers again i have trust me
that's all you got
i make 40 million dollars a year the
advisor goes on to list
all the deductions taken out of a trains
income such as
taxes there's also commissions from your
agents your managers your lawyers
me you've got two dozen people on your
payroll and that's not counting friends
and relatives and after a train tries to
justify this by claiming he has
responsibilities his advisor notes all
the speedsters crazy expenditures
13 houses a private jet an island that
you've never been to
and paying to have jan michael vincent's
ashes shot into space and then he drops
the even bigger bombshell that a train
doesn't even have the right to exploit
his own brand
get booted from the seven so what i've
still got this i'm still a train
see actually bruh you're not
see vaught owns the name the uniform
everything basically vought can
completely destroy him financially if he
attempts to use the name in any
commercial
endeavor i'm a train if i want to open
up
a trains cadillac or whatever the [ __ ] i
want to do that's exactly what i'm going
to do
now if you want to get sued and lose all
your money this is a really interesting
scene that gives some insight into
exactly how much money supes can earn if
they make it to the top tier of talent
and how ill-equipped they can be to deal
with the business side of their work
like many other celebrities
but it also shows just how expendable
they are if they fall out of favor love
sausage is one of the shall we say
more intriguing soups that the gang
discover when they break into vort
secret psych ward in the sixth episode
and after the patients take over the
asylum mother's milk suddenly finds
himself attacked by the russian man's
superpowered appendage which begins to
strangle him
mm manages to remove the monstrous thing
after kamiko
knocks love sausage out with their brass
knuckles and it recedes back into the
unconscious soup's pants
as crazy as this scene is already
originally it was going to be even
crazier in an interview with tv line
toma capon who plays frenchie revealed
that laz alonso who plays mother's milk
had pitched an idea to the episode's
director that during the fight while the
giant genitalia was wrapped around his
neck
frenchie should save him by biting the
prosthetic member off
kapon agreed and the scene was filmed
however apparently the tentacle ended up
torn to shreds and the footage wasn't
good enough to use
and because only one prosthetic had been
made they couldn't repeat the scene
according to the boys showrunner love
sausage's massive appendage was a
combination of a 10-foot long
animatronic puppet with
extra cg effects added in
post-production
leave a thumbs up if you like this
deleted scene and maybe one day the
footage will get released on a blooper
reel
there's a great kamiko scene deleted
from the fourth episode where we get to
see more of how she tries to manage the
emotional fallout from her brother's
death at the hands of stormfront
it starts with her watching one of the
secret nazis rants on social media but
then she's distracted by a rodent that's
wandered into her room she befriends the
little creature by feeding it some
snacks and then she hears the news about
stormfront's upcoming protest
let's show vote what they have to do
tomorrow morning
bot square be your own hero do not let
me down
the scene fades and we find kamiko
pacing nervously until she discovers the
friendly creature has died in a trap
underneath her bed
the animal's death is particularly
upsetting because it reminds her of her
murdered brother kenji and the nickname
mouse that she used to call him
if it looked like kamiko is in two minds
over whether to confront stormfront at
the rally
it seems like the rodent's death was
what ultimately led her to her decision
miko open the door please
there's an interesting deleted scene
from the first episode in which we see
frenchie argue with cherie over the
special relationship he has with kamiko
it's not like that okay you wanna [ __ ]
her
just spread the word we are not i will
never sleep with her
then what is she to you then i mean i
see the way you look at her
it's difficult it's difficult to explain
okay she's special
cherie doesn't buy what frenchie is
saying and mocks him to me you can
pull me by the hair me sideways but her
she's too magic and special
this scene helps to better set up the
moment later in season two when frenchie
attempts to kiss kamiko
plus it adds more weight to the scene
where he confesses to cherie that he
tried it on with her
you thought a kiss would make her feel
better or you feel better when billy
butcher turned up at the very end of the
season 2 premiere we didn't get any
proper explanation of where he'd been
between the season one finale
and reuniting with the boys this season
originally a lengthy five-minute scene
was going to fill in the gaps but it
ended up cut and released instead as a
short film titled butcher
the original scene reveals that after
butcher left tony cicero's he steals a
car
and drives to the house of an old sas
friend called jock
after reminiscing for a while about
their days in the field butcher asked
jock if he can help him find his wife
becker i thought maybe you could put
some feelers out you know
get some of the old intel boys higgins a
square all respect
yeah doesn't seem to me like your girl
wants to be found look
are you gonna help me or not of course i
am
we're mates are we after re-emerging
from the shower wearing the tracksuit
that frenchie asked him about in the
first episode butcher discovers that
jock has sold him out and called the
authorities
ordering pizza are we take it easy mate
plotters are on their way you shouldn't
have done that chuck you topped that
stillwood woman on the telly
you're gonna top your wife as well i
don't kill no one okay my billy
i'll see what you can do now you're a
killer down in the ground that don't
change
the two fight and butcher proving his
friend right and away
chokes him to death and then torches the
whole house i can see why this didn't
make it into the show because it's a
side story that isn't that crucial for
the main plot and would have slowed down
an early episode had it have been
included
it does show butcher as we've seen a few
other times at his most ruthless and
murderous
clearly his friend was betraying him
without asking butcher whether any of
the news stories are really true but
butcher certainly didn't hold back on
finishing the guy
off when he could have just
incapacitated him
there's a curious deleted scene from the
third episode with stormfront and maeve
reacting to the news leaks about vort
secretly administering compound v to
babies did you know about this
no but i mean are you really surprised
some people stood up in a board meeting
and said we could make a race of super
beings that we can
control own and monetize all we have to
do
is inject a few babies it's a shame this
scene was cut because it helps give more
reasons as to why queen maeve
changed her mind about helping starlight
in the final episode
when maeve watched stormfront stride
past her in the tower as the details of
her nazi past broke on the news she
doubtless would have remembered the
pretend stormfront made of not knowing
anything about compound v in this
deleted scene
one of stormfront's secrets is that she
was the first person who was
successfully injected with compound fee
by her nazi husband frederick vort
something she was more than happy to
disclose to homelander
we know mother's milk is all about his
family and as a way of trying to keep
himself in balance while trapped in the
boy's underground hideaway throughout
the second season we see him
constructing a large dollhouse which he
plans to give to his daughter janine
and a scene cut from episode 4 would
have revealed what happened when he
finally finished it
in the deleted scene we see eminem
meticulously dust and finish off the
grand doll house
but as he contemplates his achievement
he decides instead to offer it to
someone else
[Music]
it is all give me this
it's all yours this would have been a
nice character moment for mother's milk
because it shows him accepting the
reality of the situation that he can't
be with his family right now
so do you wish any of these deleted
scenes have been included in season 2
and would you prefer
the original ending of homeland in space
leave your thoughts in the comments
below and if you enjoyed any of these
scenes a thumbs up is hugely appreciated
next tap left to check out my full
deleted scenes and alternate endings
playlist or tap right for something else
you're sure to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time yupikai movie lovers